hey guys it is the 13th of me today my
name is Jess McDowell and you're tuned
into games but news it has been a huge
day for Microsoft but first let's take a
look at what's going on with the witcher
the witcher 3 may be all set to run
better on ps4 then it will on xbox one
if a report from Eurogamer is to be
believed CD Projekt RED co-founder
mussenden Vince t said we are still
working on squeezing the juice out of
the consoles and Microsoft is supporting
us in this respect the final effect
whether it's 720p 1080p we had the
debate in the studio about it and
actually austell tech guys to explain
how it works and they sent me some
complicated graph that if I have this
side screen and I sit one or two meters
from it then I might be able to see the
difference a Vince key also said that he
saw the 720p 1080p differentiation as
more of a PR move than something that's
meaningful to gamers and now roll that
big Microsoft news I'm not gonna make
you wait a minute longer and apparently
neither a Microsoft because they 399
dollar Xbox one without connect is
coming in tune in what can only be a
smart move head of Xbox Phil Spencer has
confirmed the news saying we heard that
you want more choices from xbox one you
want a wide variety of options in your
games and entertainment experiences and
you also want options in your hardware
selection to be clear as we introduce
this new Xbox one console option connect
remains an important part of our vision
if you want to pick up the console sands
connect it's available for pre-order at
amazon best buy and gamestop now this
news comes not a year after microsoft
exec Phil Harrison said that the company
has absolutely no plans to release Xbox
one without connect this is bothered a
few of you including book eager on site
who said since microsoft made it
absolutely clear that they would never
remove the kinect can i send them mine
for a 100-dollar refund let me know if
you think Microsoft have done the right
thing here next off the Microsoft news
truck xbox one games with gold is
launched and it kind of resembles
PlayStation Plus unlike games with gold
on the xbox 360 the service will be
description based which would seem to
suggest you can only play the games as
long as you're actively subscribed this
is pretty similar to the way that Sony
has worked there instant game collection
for PlayStation owners next month xbox
live gold subscribers will be able to
pick themselves up halo spot in the self
and max the curse of brotherhood for
free next up that pay wall keeping you
from getting to Netflix Hulu YouTube and
whatnot on your xbox is being abolished
come June you'll no longer need an xbox
live gold subscription to utilize the
video streaming services on the console
so if you've got a netflix account set
up you'll no longer need to pay more to
stream shows through your xbox one or
xbox 360 on top of this all Microsoft
apps like skype onedrive and one guide
will be available to all Xbox Live
subscribers as well as upload studio on
Xbox one let me know how you feel about
all this Marcus off teen years and
whether you reckon we'll see a surge of
Xbox one fails as a result of it those
are all the things that I wanted to tell
you about today but be sure to join me
again tomorrow for a bunch more news
until then have lovely gaming filled
evening